foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on Rumble I got the logo behind me I got
the CEO Chris pavlowski right here and
we just went public yeah we're dead do I
have to ask you any questions do you
want to talk for a while
[Music]
the building
everybody knows about it
[Music]
break down the story of Rumble and then
we'll get to what we're gonna do with
Rumble and locals yeah I know for sure
I've been in it for for two decades in
this space and it was like 2010 when I
started to notice that there was uh
like a deep prioritization happening
with all the creators uh the small
craters in particular and a real
prioritization happening around 2010
around multi-channel networks
[Music]
um Brands corporations they just they
they left the the aunt the uncle the
friends and family behind on on these
incumbent platforms so by 2013 I was
like let's build something for the small
guy and really help the small Creator
give them the same monetization tools
that everyone can get the same playing
field just keep it fair
you saw it way early I mean 2013 yeah I
saw it when like YouTube did this pivot
to multi-channel networks uh you
probably remember Maker Studios they
started pref they use these companies to
start preferencing content and they
really started de-prioritizing the small
guy making the viral video and then you
know I kind of stepped on the gas pedal
in in 2013 thinking you know it's time
to get back in
um and we did just bring in the
monetization tools like simple things
like just an evil an equal playing
Ground you know you can monetize your
video know as soon as you upload it
doesn't matter how big you are you know
that you'd think that would basically
that we all kind of but that doesn't
happen it's not it's not something that
happens there so we did that we started
in 2013 and then by 2020 you know you
that everything hits the fan [ __ ] hits
the fan yeah and uh because you can say
[ __ ] we're on road yeah yeah yeah that's
right so like in the middle is I would
say late summer
um we had uh you know I was a Canadian
I'm a Canadian yeah and uh we had the
ranking member of the House Intel
committee
sign up to rumble and want to jump on a
call with me and I'm like holy [ __ ] am I
under some kind of Investigation like
what's going on like and uh it's it's
Congressman Devin Nunes and he um
he asked me a really simple question
he's like Chris if I come to uh Rumble
and I search for my name and my content
are you going to show up and I'm like
guys it's gonna show up when you put the
name in right like this can't like right
thinking he's looking for like some kind
of censorship it's like just a basic
yeah of course it's going to show up
like right absolutely like that's what
[ __ ] happened he's like well that's not
happening on any of any of the platforms
and I'm you know and I kind of knew that
already and I already because I knew of
the preferencing and everything else so
he comes on and then following that
subsequent to that you know is when Dan
bongino signs up and comes on in late
September and then from there you know
everything's history so so by you know
six months later we had an entire a huge
political segment on Rumble you know six
months after that we attracted people
like uh congresswoman democratic
congresswoman Tulsi gabbard and former
Democratic presidential candidate uh
Tulsi gabbard in the middle of the
summer with along with Glenn Greenwald
onto the platform that was huge and by
the end of the year we had people like
Russell Brand signed up unsolicited just
totally signs up to the platform I think
it was in September of 2021
um I didn't find out two weeks later and
then we get to 2022 we had this like
Bitcoin conference get de platformed by
YouTube during the live stream you know
we were there to help them out
um then you had Oliver Stone's movie get
removed and then you had like a
left-wing activist like Susan Sarandon
started tweeting Rumble and this starts
blossoming and then you get to the
summer and then
something happened over this this late
summer that you know I've never seen at
Rumble we've seen lots of growth really
fast but then you know we exploded uh we
by in June we had 35 million people in
the United States on Rumble in August we
had 63 million in U.S and Canada crazy
crazy just to put that number in
perspective like what is you what does
YouTube have in in the United States on
a monthly active user basis what does
Twitter have and like I don't know well
YouTube's roughly 200 million Twitter's
roughly 68. we're at 63 in US and Canada
so like how close are we we're very
close closed captioning not available
primarily so like
it's a lot 63 versus 68 on Twitter I
just got to keep saying that because
like and Twitter was not growing when
they hit the last time the reported 68
which was in 2019 there was like
consecutive quarters between 60 and 70.
so you know when I look at that I I
really you really kind of get a feeling
of how big this really is and then going
public
ringing the bell
you know I
but we needed to do that yeah it's free
we would not be able to defend Free
Speech will not be able to defend
freedom if we did it from the sidelines
we have to go right in their playground
and we got to play with them and we got
to push back and that's what we're going
to do and no company at least that I
know of has ever started and gone public
with the mission of free speech I mean
that is our mission when when you me and
Assaf sit down and we talk about all
this stuff that's what we're talking
about the entire time that's what we're
talking about all the time it's like
core it's ingrained in every person we
hire it's across the team
freedom of expression free speech
freedom in general is something that
we're all standing for from the top all
the way to the lowest levels and you
know
when Elon was talking about buying
Twitter I always said like
it's not built the same way Rumble is
built you're not going to have that
strength from top to bottom you're gonna
have a lot of problems after the
acquisition how that's going to look I
don't even know but you're gonna have an
exodus you're gonna have a lot of good
Engineers leaving every engineer on this
team is all in on that they're in
they're in and and they're going to work
twice as hard because they care yeah
they care like I do they care like you
do so it's like that's
that's the real the real magic in what's
happening and like I can't I I couldn't
wait for this day because I thought
somebody was going to stop us from
happening but like the fact that we're
here now now and we've raised the amount
of money that we raised yeah
approximately 400 million dollars
Now's the Time we can push now so I can
ask you the easy ones all day long but
actually in my locals Community people
were asking tough questions and I said
I'm gonna ask you some tough ones you
said nothing's off the table so the main
thing that people are asking is okay so
now we've defended Free Speech well
Rumble allows plurality of voices all
sorts of political opinions as you said
you got Glenn and Tulsi on the left you
got bongino on the right okay Russell
Brand as well Russell Brand like there's
there's a big there's a big plurality
but uh what do you do now that you're
public to make sure that all of the
people and the companies and the voices
that make get people de-platformed and
get you know what are we going to do
about that so it starts with all your
employees they have to be aligned and
every brick we add to rumble is aligned
on this mission
secondly management the board
all of them are aligned they all
really care about the free and open
internet and protecting that
third legally speaking you know it's on
our corporate site that our whole
mission is to be anti-cancel culture our
whole mission is to restore and protect
the free and open internet so if I were
to do something contrary to that I have
a huge liability to all the investors
and when it comes to like investors now
now that we're public you have to
remember that I have you know roughly I
think 85 percent vote control you're
doing all right you're doing all right
it's going to be very difficult to
change the way I'm going to think
um and you're definitely not going to
change the the staff that we have on
Rumble we all think the same and you're
not going to change my mind this is this
is I I could have sold this business I
didn't
um and I didn't because like it's it
really matters to the kids out there it
matters to to people out there Freedom
like I didn't think I was going to be
defending freedom but we have no choice
like what's happening out there right
now people not allowing to be said
saying what they want to say guys like
Steve will do it getting the platform
even know why like
this is this is way bigger than me it's
way bigger than you it's way bigger than
all of us it's it's it's something we're
now in we're now in a playground where
we can actually push back and you know
we're we're beholden to
the team that we have the management
that we have the investors that we have
and you know everyone always asks the
question like if you go public are they
going to be able to like is some huge
company going to come in and invest and
be able to influence you well they don't
have 85 control So my answer to that is
how can they technically and legally
speaking how can they if an investor
wants to invest in this company and
wants to change the the mission of this
company I'm gonna go tell them this is
not the company to invest in don't
invest in us if you want to invest in US
here's our mission you need to be
aligned and by the way we don't need
money right now you know right like it's
like we don't we raised yeah
approximately 400 million dollars and
whoever wants to invest in Rumble you
know they need to believe in what we
what we're doing yeah and the people
that don't believe in what we're doing
they're not going to invest in us and if
they try to try to influence us I'm
going to be like this is not right for
you then like look this is what we're
doing yeah I got a liability to to to my
old staff and to the rest of the
investors out there that this is what
we're doing
I'll look at the camera for this one I
can tell my audience that having
partnered through locals with Rumble and
with Chris every single thing that Chris
has said to me over the last two plus
years that we've been doing this you
were laying out crazy things all along
the way and every single thing that he
said came true so this has been a plan
believe in this guy I believe in what
we're doing obviously let me just ask
you one other thing uh because I you got
a lot of people you got to talk to over
here uh on the on the cloud side can you
just talk about that part of the
business a little bit because I think a
lot of people still think of Rumble as
sort of a YouTube replacement something
like that but there's much more here and
I'll get into some of that with this off
in a few minutes yeah you think of like
Rumble it's a good vehicle for
information flow like people can get
their voices heard but like with it you
don't you can't have information flow
until you have the infrastructure that
can support them so it's really
imperative that we do that and we've
made a lot of progress on that we
launched you know one of the largest
fastest growing apps out there which
truth social which is truth social
flawlessly onto our Cloud by late we
also launched Tim pools well onto the
cloud and by late 2023 we plan to make
this public for everyone for state
governments for governments that believe
in our mission and our cause
for universities religious institutions
small businesses around the world
there's a huge market so this is this is
going at Amazon AWS yeah head on head on
because like we have a different value
set than they do and we believe that the
market believes in our value set more
than they believe in theirs and I really
really believe that and I do too you can
kind of see it in the numbers and Rumble
like I said 63 million people in the US
and Canada they're not all just watching
politics I can tell you that they're not
we were 35 to 63 and that's because we
retracted a large portion of the Gen Z
and they're not looking at political
videos they're looking at like cool fun
videos that that's what they're looking
for so it's completely different but
yeah and big Tech is knocking off the
guys that aren't purely political we got
Steve from the note boys over here he's
going to jump on in a second like he got
booted I grew like we grew this thing
without spending enormous dollars of
marketing this is because of
people losing trust in the incumbent
platforms and it's imperative that we
never lose that trust yeah it's
absolutely imperative because
you know that's that that's that's the
core and like if if we if we ever did
anything that was contrary to our
mission we should lose the trust it's on
us as a business it's on us to do well
and be good Chris you have been a man of
your word throughout should we bring you
want to be stay here for a few minutes
while Steve jumps in why don't we get
Stephen Steve from the milk boys get it
Steve did it he's got the uh the 420 I
don't know what that means come on Steve
we're going to get you on over there oh
he's posting he's posted he's posting
right he's posted for the show all right
so all right we'll go a little longer
Steve's gonna come in just a second he
just pounded a couple Champagnes the
guys
boom boom boom I have water I have water
you got nothing
um
how do you feel about this because this
is this was your baby and this is what
we did today what you did today this is
the dream of everyone that built this
company it truly to press that button
that Bell wait I said it was a button
right yeah
um it's the Dream It's the dream yeah
kind of the dream but not really like
this is just to me it's kind of
you know it's not the real work it's
it's cool yeah but it's not me like
these fancy parties and stuff like that
like really care less but
um it's cool my I think like getting
here is really important to do what we
need to do but the real works ahead of
us like you know
um in my game face is on more than ever
now like it's uh I I don't want to
downplay today or anything I love it
it's great it's amazing it's just like
no I can tell you what you want to get
back in the office yeah already yeah
it's really just like
to do what we what we need to do and
like that's that's more meaningful to me
so you know all this you know Times
Square our logo up there it's awesome
it's great but like you know we haven't
done it until we really push back
against these guys and everyone kind of
like we tilt the market back to where
it's supposed to be yeah like that's all
I really care about when I do that
that's when I'm going to celebrate every
time every time we almost got them every
time there's uh you know somebody kicked
off one of these platforms at this point
are you basically licking your chops
because we we get a text going and it's
like all right hey they can join us
there I'm kind of like what are they
doing yeah like I never thought we would
continue to grow because they continue
to accelerate it right I'm ready to be
right they're doing awesome yeah like we
raise 400 million in an effort to really
try to compete against them and go and
bring on creators and they're just
giving it to us for free still like like
that I'm not licking my chops I'm kind
of disappointed more than anything like
why I don't want to win like that like
that's that's not that's not good for
society isn't it weird you can freely
admit that knowing that they're not
going to fix the problem on their own
knowing that YouTuber Google or Facebook
is going to go you know Chris is on to
us rumbles on to us and well let's
reverse course fun like last year yeah
like it got worse this summer yeah way
worse and I don't know if you know this
but we got an election coming here in
America since it might get worse once
again well it's accelerating as we speak
yeah right all right we're gonna get
Steve from the delcois oh he's got the
handheld no no he's Steve from Rumble
now he's Steve from Rumble
Steve look at that Jersey eh hold on
wait wait wait we got you gotta show off
The Jersey though like the best parts of
the back like
Steve did it tell us what he likes Steve
did it he knows what he likes Steve did
it there you go he did do it
why'd you jump in on this crazy
adventure this crazy Rumble Adventure I
love I love making content I love
changing people's lives and you know I
got you know canceled
for whatever reason yeah do you know why
you got I mean it's basically because
you talk to a certain guy right
an orange guy I couldn't tell you why
yeah that is a big thing I talked to an
orange guy yeah I gave an orange guy a a
nice watch yeah but to me I really don't
know why I got canceled because I got
canceled for a URL uh to a website
the.com and that website you're allowed
to openly promote on YouTube's show
you're playing show you're on that
website on YouTube so I really don't
understand the the
the true reason behind it yeah getting
canceled for a website that's allowed on
the platform they just don't allow.com
so it's uh it's very mind-blowing yeah
considering I've never even showed the
website on my main Channel it was a
second channel that gets 100K views per
video and you know I get four million
views per video but they
shut out my main channel for that and
it's like I would kind of understand if
the website was not prohibited on
YouTube but you're allowed to say hey
I'm playing on this website hey
live uh record the website yeah and I
got banned for having the.com of that
website you're allowed to use it I got
it so there's no Rhyme or Reason kind of
like you know when you just say it for
what it is you know what was that moment
like for you when you see the thing blow
up and you see the bands coming and
you're going yeah I got a business too I
mean it's not just you having fun right
it's [ __ ] mind-blowing because like I
said
it's a mind [ __ ] when you get banned for
something
that they allow on their platform yeah
so and it's like on your second channel
it's kind of like yeah you just feel
like and then dude but what about on the
business side I mean it's your life it's
your life too yeah the business side
thank God I have great Partners here we
go this guy
but besides they think I have someone
like Chris that's you know down that
calls me and you know gives me a
fantastic deal and welcomes me with
opens arms so rumbles but thank God I
have if I didn't have like Kyle Johnson
the milk boys and everyone like I would
be absolutely [ __ ] and it was just
like for no reason and they don't have
to give you a legitimate reason and it
sucks it sucks how it works man well now
you're in the fight with us yeah pretty
sweet yeah pretty sweet it's nice to
just be able to upload a video and be
proud about it and go to bed and just
know it's not getting deleted because I
would always go to bed on when it comes
to Instagram and YouTube and just be
like
[ __ ] like you don't know right you just
don't know and you're not going to
censor this guy no matter no matter how
many f-bombs he drops on the Reuben
report the difference between Chris
you've definitely set my show record for
f-bombs oh I love you [ __ ] but [ __ ]
part of my [ __ ] vocabulary the
difference between [ __ ] Chris and
[ __ ] YouTube is that he'll give me a
call and be like hey Steve
what you're doing is [ __ ] wrong like
you got to change it up and YouTube
never gave me a call or let me know they
called me the day of deletion and it was
a girl and
she seemed pretty stoked I was getting
deleted and I was like the the set yeah
it seemed happy and I was like I was
with me and my editor and I'm like we're
like bro like she's happy yeah like like
she like like you're giving someone like
the worst news possible and you're doing
it in a way to where it's like
like a [ __ ] like you're happy and it was
kind of just [ __ ] up and I wish I
recorded it but it was a mind [ __ ] you
know that's messed that's this like
that's I have a feeling you're not gonna
get that call from this guy you're gonna
be all right no if I get a call just be
like hey like Yo dude you're doing this
wrong like let's change it up this is
our policies and it's like
that's that's that's what I wanted from
YouTube but they they didn't respect me
as a Creator considering they didn't
give me a 100K plaque you know when you
I got the 100K plan you know they don't
like me that much you get 100 000
subscribers you get the plaque you
[ __ ] hang on your wall you look at
that [ __ ] yeah you put in your bathroom
you're taking [ __ ] you look at me like
yo I did that [ __ ] you get a million
subscribers look at that you know you're
chilling on TVs look at me like yo
that's me yeah they didn't give that to
me damn and it's like they're so they
were against me from the beginning
because you got to think I got a million
subscribers in a month
so it's like from the very beginning
they were against me because I got that
[ __ ] I got 100K subscribers we give
plaques we're good all right we got it
yeah
when I get a million subscribers on
Rumble which is gonna happen yeah I'm
gonna have the sexiest plaque in the
world and in the world and it's gonna
just
[ __ ] YouTube it's gonna be [ __ ] you
I mean one it's like bro I you don't
just get you can't it's not a cheat code
to get a million subscribers you don't
you can't cheat and get a million
subscribers I got a million subscribers
because a million people genuinely liked
me
and I felt like I deserved it and they
said
as YouTube we get to choose who we give
the plaques to and it's like hey like
what it's kind of [ __ ] up like why you
know like if I was a makeup artist I
would have got that Millions the million
subscriber pack like like that but the
fact that I was just like this guy that
appeals to like high school college kids
and just like I'm kind of like
dark humor goofy do my thing which I
think dark humor and Goofy is acceptable
in this world I feel yeah it's
acceptable in this world I feel like
that's a thing that should be except and
and they didn't they didn't see it I
don't know why I I always think politics
but at the same time I'm not very
political
but I did give uh you know Donald Trump
a Rolex and I feel like that [ __ ] up
my entire career
I think it [ __ ] up everything that had
going I gave him I feel like you're not
the first person to say that bro it's
not it has nothing to do with politics
this guy makes me laugh yeah he's funny
dude like dude I'm literally uh like
anyone that makes me genuinely laugh
like I'm gonna like I'll give them
anything like there's not a lot of
people that can make me laugh in today's
age because everything's so censored
like there's only like there's like a
few comedians that are like actually
dark humored
that can make me laugh and they're so
rare because they're it's so censored
and I consider Donald Trump a dark
humored comedian honestly I wasn't
political yeah and YouTube I guess took
it at as me being political it's like no
I think this guy's funny like I think I
think locker room talks funny I would
like to thank YouTube for what they did
for you because uh they brought you over
here and that's yeah everything since
this is a slightly different NASDAQ
conversation than they're having on the
average day yeah no kidding yeah I think
I think I think everything happens for a
reason and um you know when I got my
[ __ ] deleted it was like what the [ __ ]
like I've spent my entire life you know
I lived for a long time I would make you
know just between us and this [ __ ]
live stream yeah
you know I would make a million and a
half per month
and I would spend a million and a half
per month
towards
just random people you know those [ __ ]
it was like and I just never in my head
I was like how
I'd never thought about being canceled
so I was like okay I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna devote my life to this [ __ ] and
you know we're gonna build Brands sell
it and it's like I'm Gonna Change the
World
and it was like oh you can just get
canceled like that but it was like I
literally thought in my head like hey
I'm gonna
devote my entire income to helping
people in the world
and then build brands
while I'm doing that so I so I'm not a
loser at the end of it I could sell it
get 100 million dollars
get the island whether that but it was
like I guess you can get canceled for
using uh.com on a website
that the platform allows you to play on
it just makes no sense yeah you want to
get into it like you know what you don't
have to worry about it anymore
no you're good you're good it's truly
[ __ ] up when you like when you say it
out loud to what it is like like using a
like showing the URL of a website that
you're allowed to promote and play on
the platform well they were just looking
for a reason I know but it's like yeah
when I get deleted and then and then and
then the girls like happy about it with
the ton of it's like I just can't like
it's like a mind [ __ ] yeah
it's you know all right Chris we gotta
make we got to make this guy a lot of
money so that he can do good things in
the world so he can get that out yeah
all right
this first video is going to be probably
gonna be insane I say I say I say in one
month and it's gonna be the greatest
video that he's ever made it's gonna be
the most life-changing Beautiful video
in the world and you know things I'm
gonna sleep like a goddamn [ __ ] baby
that night I'm gonna sleep like a
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying I got
it the only I'm gonna be a little
worried about Instagram because I'm a
pro on Instagram but I'm gonna go to bed
knowing that that video is gonna be
[ __ ] live the next day and if there's
a problem I'm gonna get a phone call and
be like hey there's a problem we're not
gonna just get
canceled out of the blue so this is very
exciting for me and exclusively exclude
yeah I am exclusive on Rumble all right
and Dave thank you so much Chris Chris
changed my life no no Steve did it I'm
just so happy this guy came up thank you
so much Chris is this uh this is where
you present me with the Rolex right
chassis would be fun yeah a lot of
viewers well you're awesome man I'm
thrilled that you're part of this
freaking thing and and this is just the
beginning so uh beginning all these
strange allies just pop out of the
woodwork you know what I mean if you
would have told me that we'd be sitting
here a month ago I'd be like what the
hell are you talking about and yeah easy
and yet here we are yeah and it's a
beautiful thing like I love like I'm so
just about positivity and spreading that
and I'm so not political so it's like
kind of cool to just have a platform
that's just like doesn't give a [ __ ] if
you're political or anything no I could
be the most liberal left-wing
guy yeah on on Rumble and I will be
allowed my [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
like that's the beauty of it that's
that's why I [ __ ] we got good but
that's why I love it because Chris
because Chris could give me the deal
that he gave me and then I could be like
yo buddy I'm [ __ ] the biggest Biden
supporter in the world I'm gonna rep the
[ __ ] he wouldn't give a [ __ ] it's not
it's not about politics no it's about
content entertainment like YouTube is
content entertainment it's for the
people it's like why do we need to get
in this adult politic [ __ ] like long as
a [ __ ] like I don't give a [ __ ] yeah my
fans don't give a [ __ ] about I I mean I
I'm speaking for my fans but I truly
believe that that my fans that are 16 to
30 years old don't truly give a [ __ ]
that much about politics like that and
they're basing it it sucks that you have
to base the entire world and every tech
company around politics you know not
anymore man not anymore but I just hope
I just hope that it stays that Rumble
stays the thing because you know it's a
[ __ ] War at the yeah you know like
Rumble could get like I don't know I
don't know we can't get deleted no we
got we got no it's a war so like for you
guys to even go public and do all this
it's like you guys are like kind of
winning that war it's like it's it's
crazy the Insurgency is here yeah so I
hope thank you so much glad to be
partnered with you I'm glad to be on it
I'm glad to make videos all I like to do
get yourself some champagne man I'm
gonna get Champagne by if you guys
watching I'm gonna make videos
in like two to three two to four weeks
from now and it's like I love making
videos I love changing lives uh I'm
gonna say this right now no disrespect
to YouTube but [ __ ] you YouTube no
disrespect but like you banned me for a
website that you allow on your platform
like if you're gonna ban me for a
website on my second Channel I guess
100K like at least and not allow it on
your platform you [ __ ] communist
[ __ ] like like bammy because I did
something wrong don't ban me for a
fucking.com on a what on my second
Channel like it's 100K views for a
website that you [ __ ] allow you allow
this website we'll just say it all right
you're gonna be all right I'm gonna be
all right but it just pisses me off and
you know new opportunity and YouTube you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
you you I have real fans YouTube you
don't have real fans you're a bunch of
commie bastards [ __ ] you I'm so sorry is
this live
you know what the beauty about Rumble is
you can make mistakes I like that you're
getting closer to the camera it's like
really you know oh but the thing is you
guys
banned me for a website that you allow
on your platform like let's like let's
let that sink in
I hear you man they've been they've been
hitting me for a long time but imagine
like all right we'll just not even
Rolexes out we'll save for Reddit is
okay
hey my name's YouTube hey buddy how you
doing
um you can um there's this website
called steak.com you can play it on on
our platform you can show you Planet you
can say hey verbally hey I'm on stake
it's the best gambling website ever you
can say that but if you have that.com
that is [ __ ] bad yeah you are
promoting a bad website yeah you are a
scum bag piece of [ __ ] if they see
that.com you know you're gonna get
people to gamble but you know things you
gamble on that website tell them that
you're playing on that website save
where you're playing show them that
you're playing show but if you show
that.com
because all these guys are idiots they
don't know how to they don't know how to
get to that website unless there's
the.com they just think steak like
they're gonna think like ribeye yeah but
that's that's what I'm dealing with
makes no sense
so I love you guys I'm probably getting
calls from from my business partner
saying hey you need to chill the [ __ ]
out
but
um I love you guys so much big videos
coming Steve will do videos going live
um I love you guys thank you for so much
for having me thanks brother thank you
so much all right uh
I can't tell there's a screen okay this
is the camera okay I love you guys
Steve will do a sign out once a week
Steve
that was definitely the most colorful uh
thing that has ever happened at NASDAQ
and I think indicative of uh what's
going on over here at Rumble the whole
point is that nobody if you're a Dark
comic because you're giving Rolexes to
Trump if you're a lefty like Glenn
Greenwald or Tulsi gabbard or you're a
crazy right winger like Dave Rubin or
Dan bongino you are welcome to be on
this platform free speech is going
public that is the purpose of all this
that's why we're doing this from NASDAQ
right now that's why the company went
public everyone has an opportunity to
get in on it and stick it to Google and
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter and the
rest of these things that made us the
product when we thought they were the
product it is pretty awesome and
speaking of awesome I'm going to bring
on now now we will we're going to ease
up on the the foul language I think for
just a moment I am going to bring on the
co-founder and CEO of locals who also
happens to be my brother-in-law I let
him marry my sister a soft love hello
Assaf nice to seal will shake hands
so I for my audience
we started they've been with me forever
they heard the adventure of let's start
something let's build something all of
that and I went to you and I was like
Assaf can you build me my own basically
a patreon replacement can we build a
subscription model here can we do it you
built it and then we were like let's
build a company and now it's about two
and a half years later and we merged
with Rumble and Republic uh
pretty sweet yeah you know it's funny
because when you think about it exactly
three years ago September of 2019 oh
yeah this is time that we launched the
Ruby report Community yeah and yes Dave
came to me at the time you were with
patreon if you remember at the end of
2018 and he said Asaf I need a solution
where I'm going to control my audience
where I will be the boss for my own
business because I cannot rely on those
big Tech and we started to do it but it
was one element that we added to the
mixer that we said it it's not only that
we wanted to build a solution when you
own the data and you own your user but
also a place where your user can connect
to one another and we build it all under
a community and three years ago we
launched the Ruben report community and
I think the power of the community that
we discover is much greater than
anything else yeah because
um the Ruby report Community allowed us
to hire the key employees that we have
in the company yeah the Reuben report we
got I mean literally you're not making
that up I mean we got some of our key
staff members there are people like
they're high up they were up there yes
celebrating that were fans they were
literally fans of the show they reached
out to me and were like how can I get
involved this is my skill set I want to
throw some dollars in whatever it might
be another part of this operation
because that's the point of the
community that's the point of the
community we got some investors to back
it up and we built the product with one
thing in mind we said how can we support
free speech and how can we build a
solution where we think about the
Creator first and then you connected me
to some like uh really interesting
creators that had similar problems yeah
and we started to give it to more and
more creators and we discover a need in
the industry and the need is that the
Creator want to have full control and
connect directly with the audience but I
think what we see recently and why we
are now with rumbel the entire media
landscape is changing in front of our
eyes if in the past you needed social
media to basically have a distribution
Channel today distribution channels are
people like yourself that already have
an audience and we are betting big time
on Creative Independence and we want to
help more and more creators we saw Steve
will do it it by the way is opening his
own locals Community Steve will do it at
locals.com oh not bad not bad that it's
going to be available as well we want to
see more people like yourself more
creative successful because you guys are
the future of distribution and it's
interesting also because not only so we
build a good product but our mission was
the same mission that Chris was building
with Rumble the entire time so when we
sat down with him which was only
basically a year and half ago and we
were trying to figure out could we just
work together and basically he was like
forget working together we need to join
forces we need we need to be together
yeah and it happened pretty quick it
happened pretty quick I have to say that
um in the beginning when we went to
people and you know that we had some
investors missed the opportunity because
when there's a lot of people eating crow
today yeah yes because uh when they
heard that we support Free Speech it was
like people got nervous yeah they
thought Free Speech was some some
right-wing thing that was always the
worry and we kept saying no it isn't
they're coming for everybody this isn't
about politics the lefties can be on
here but a certain amount of people are
always afraid yeah so we got the right
investors and I'm very proud of every
investor that joined uh locals and I
think it's a celebration day for them as
well but when we met Chris it was the
first time that we met the tech CEO that
taught in the same way that he said you
know what we can have a platform where
we allow people to share their opinion
regardless if we agree or disagree with
them as long as they obey the laws of
the United States and the Synergy was
perfect we started the partnership and I
think quickly after we got the offer to
join rambel and for us I think not only
that it was a great success working
together for the past three years it was
the first ride to get to the moment that
we are ringing the bell together with
rumbel but essentially what we are doing
we are taking Free Speech public and I'm
here in the United States for almost 10
years yeah I think there is one value
new citizen of the United States by the
way thank you very much yes and there is
one value that is unique to United
States by the way and its freedom and as
long as I'm here and as long as I can
like you know help to contribute to this
I'm going to fight for freedom and I
think that's what rambel is doing at the
end of the day you know I know you've
only done a couple interviews but that
was a that was a I'm learning from the
best nice and tight my man you really
tied that thing together
um Can we is there anything we can hint
to the people that might be on the
horizon you know my Local's community
and obviously probably all of them are
watching right now it's a big day uh
they're always asking me what's next
what's next I've been hinting some
things that we're working on and we've
improved our video live streaming
tremendously and a whole bunch of is
there anything we can hint at maybe or
yeah we're going to give a few so first
life sleep is something that we're going
to be uh very bullish and we're going to
keep on improving it more and more the
reason it's because it's the most
authentic form of communication that you
have but what we want to do now and
that's going to come in 2023 we want to
see how we can involve the audience as
well I think that you always say that
your community and you learn a lot from
your community as well you want them to
be more involved in the live stream and
we are going to develop some feature
that will allow them to be more
interactive I call it interactive media
and that's really where we're going to
go the second thing that we released
actually this month was articles because
was what we understand is that creators
not only want to produce videos they
also want to have written content so now
you can also write articles on locals
and you can expand the type of content
that you have and the third thing that
we started in the past few months we
started to sell movies on locals and we
have tremendous success I mean we did
2000 mules through the Nash and he
absolutely crushed it to say the least
yeah and what Dinesh proved is the
locals Mission what Dinesh proved was
that he can take a movie that he produce
and he can go independent and do it
himself and the results that he got was
mind-blowing and I think now we're gonna
open it up so in the uh in the near
future you guys are going to hear about
it as well it's something that we call
content plus essentially we believe that
every Creator can create their own
on-demand service on their platform
where they can sell movies they can sell
articles if they want they can sell
podcasts and we want to more Empower you
guys to be build your own business
that's something that we're going to be
committed for to keep empowering our
creators to be independent because we
think that they are the future of media
I heard a rumor that Rumble might go
into the email business perhaps there's
some messaging coming some private
messaging for the people on the local
side there's all kinds of things a lot
down the pike there is a lot of things
and a lot of things that people also
need to understand from rumbel one of
the big reason why we started to even
like talk to Amber to begin with we knew
that we cannot be hosted on big Tech
yeah and we knew that the big challenge
with building our technology if you
remember a lot of people came to us and
say where are you being hosted it's not
easy to build this infrastructure and
now I can tell you from The Insider the
rambel infostatic infrastructure team
are world class yeah those are
world-class people and we are building
more and more servers to basically
support more people and that they can
speak up so we build it on top of it but
now it's going to be time that we are
going to roll out more feature is what
you said more communication more
messaging more involving the community
itself in connecting with the creators
Asaf maybe I'll see you for dinner at
your place tonight I guess you're going
to see it but that was quite a journey
Dave yeah it is only the beginning it is
only the beginning all right I'm gonna
talk to the camera for a few minutes
here thank you what's up because you
guys sent in a gajillion questions here
I do want to get to some and uh
hopefully I think probably asafa and
Chris answered a few of them Steve may
have answered some of them in his own
special sort of way uh but I'll just
jump through a couple of them and uh as
you can tell guys this really is just a
great day putting aside that I that in a
weird way putting aside that I have
anything to do with this thing that I
created locals that we merged with
Rumble the the message that I'm always
talking to you guys here about on the
political side that the only way we can
make sense of anything these days is if
we can honestly talk about it if we can
truly hear what the opinions are if we
can hear counter opinions if we can
figure out what's true and what is
information versus misinformation that's
the mission that Rumble is on you know
it really is this this was the company
that I was supposed to end up working
with through locals and that that's the
plan and I think it really is a piece of
fixing all of the political stuff that I
normally do a show about that obviously
I will get back to doing so let me jump
into a couple questions here from you
guys uh small says aside from attracting
new talent to the platform how do you
plan to grow the business so Assaf just
hit on some of that on the feature side
but really you know doing the cloud
services uh really you know replacing
replacing or going right up against them
whatever you want to call it Amazon AWS
Amazon web services AWS Amazon web
services you know those are the guys
that blew up parlor they basically
pressed the button they said you have 23
million view users doesn't matter if
they're good guys bad guys or anything
else we're taking you out because you're
a competition that is what Rumble is
really building and and there is a
tremendous amount of infrastructure
already and a lot more on the horizon I
don't know what I'm allowed to say so
we'll leave it at that uh let's see
Cobalt says apparently twitch is losing
gaming creators to YouTube because of
monetization pause these I just heard
more a little bit more about this this
morning will Rumble try to attract to uh
will Rumble try to attract some to join
exclusively also when will Rumble ads
start showing up for creators the ad
thing is going to be laid out over the
next little bit it's already in the
works I've seen the beta testing on that
stuff and 100 yes on the gamers the
whole point of Rumble is that we're an
agnostic platform in that sense you know
it's thought of maybe as a little bit
political because well because I'm here
and because bongino's here and Crowder
uses Rumble and Tim pools using our
infrastructure and all of those things
so that's sort of what's put the
attention on it and the media loves to
write if you know if you get a couple
conservatives or scary right-wing people
on something the media immediately tries
to label it that but the point of the
platform is we don't care if you're a
lefty YouTuber or a righty gamer or a
gender mending economist
uh which I assume is out there probably
uh you know it's like if you're doing
something interesting and you have an
audience you should be on Rumble and
that's what you should be doing
um Jazzy says do you Dan talking about
Dan bongino and the main players at
Rumble have a plan to always keep
majority shares to keep Free Speech free
so that's what uh Chris the CEO
addressed earlier he has 85 controlling
share uh I know Chris very well at this
point like this is a guy who not only
stayed true to his word the entire time
we were doing the merger and and all of
the
the policies he's brought me and Dan in
you know I don't own the company anymore
I don't own locals anymore
um but Dan and I help guide the policy
what can we do to make sure that we can
be as open as possible so that all the
whackadoodles on YouTube who don't like
Dave Rubin and do these videos all day
long you want to do those videos on
Rumble that's all right that's all right
we welcome you to do it that will be
just great I welcome you people so we're
gonna we're gonna really I I truly
believe this this is the first company
that has gone public saying Free Speech
open inquiry debate is in our ethos it
is in the DNA of what we do and and I
don't think that's been done with and
well it certainly hasn't been done with
any of the big tech companies before in
many cases they've actually done the
reverse right they've said okay we have
these algorithms how can we make sure
certain people are either banned or
censored or Shadow banned or
algorithmically you know unpersoned Etc
et cetera so that that is the challenge
for us but it is it is what we started
doing and what we will continue to do
Jay Paul says what's the ticker symbol
we got a great how I don't know how this
ticker symbol was not taken we got r-u-m
rum as in I'm gonna have a mojito with
two shots of rum uh so we have r-u-m uh
which is now being traded on NASDAQ and
I assume doing pretty well today I don't
know I'm in a giant NASDAQ room I don't
see a ticker in front of me there's a
lot of screens all over the place uh
let's see uh David's Moore says so proud
of you guys what was the one part of
taking this public that was harder or
easier than expected well
I can tell you that building locals you
know one thing that probably is hard for
you guys to appreciate or understand and
in retrospect I almost think I was crazy
for doing it was like we said okay we're
going to fight big Tech that's just nuts
in and of itself and then I was like all
right I'll build a tech company and
Assaf was handling the tech side but I
had to be in all the investor meetings
and you know you'd go into meetings with
people you do for every one investor you
get you probably have 50 that say no
right maybe even more our numbers were
pretty good like we had a great product
and because people knew me there was
like it was a little bit maybe easier
for us than the average startup
um but I would say honestly 60 to 70
percent of my time of 2000 and 2001 were
dedicated to building locals more than
doing the show in a way I gave
everything I always give everything I
have to the show but every minute of
time that I had outside of the show was
on Zoom calls doing the pitches deciding
what were our policies on speech and
what were we going to do if this or that
happened and all of those things so I
would say it's uh it's a little sort of
like youthful naivete in a way it's like
now that I did this once I think we
could probably do it again and I've got
a couple other ideas on that front and I
want to do a lot more obviously with
these guys but
um the the hardest part was
the hardest part was just you just keep
going a lot of people people that you
know and friends and you know I know
people in the tech world that say no to
you or ignore you or don't call you back
after a great pitch and at some point
you want to give up there's always those
moments and you just go and you go and
you go and I I really believe if you if
you have something good and you give it
your all whatever that might be
Tech Sports you're a shoe salesman you
can do it I really believe that uh let's
see uh Gail says would you explain the
business relationship between locals and
Rumble again yes we merged as companies
so so you can sort of look at it this
way Rumble which is now the public
company is the is the parent company of
locals in effect locals is run exactly
100 the same way it was run before the
acquisition before the merger as it was
after
um so asafa is the CEO of locals he
handles it we have separate offices in
uh in Miami local Rumble is over in
Sarasota so we're taking over the free
state of Florida on both coasts which is
awesome but the companies are they are
one company right now uh let's see what
else can I uh do a couple more for you
Becca says are there any further
developments for bundle subscriptions
for locals uh five to ten adds up
quickly if we want content from multiple
creators yes this has been one of the
things that you guys have asked about
from the beginning it has been very
complex to figure out how to do it
because you sort of have to tear out
creators and who is making the most who
has the most draw who would be willing
to take less to be in a bundle with say
a bigger Creator we've been trying to
figure it out we have a couple models on
it I think we're getting close I don't
want to over promise at the moment but
yes the the general concept of that you
know asaph and I when we started locals
I kept saying I want more people
involved even if we make less money I
was very clear about that from the
beginning and that's why when I get get
emails and if you're struggling
financially or if you're a former member
of the military you're out of work
because of some of the covid nonsense or
vaccinations it's like I give people
free memberships it's fine it's fine
it's I'm fine it'll be fine
um but we do understand that you know it
adds up over time right if you love 10
people on locals and you know I charge
five dollars a month
but some people charge 7 or 10 or 12.
that's going to add up pretty quickly
and that's not really the purpose of the
company we want to defend Free Speech we
want as many people to be involved in a
better internet as possible those of you
that are watching right now in the live
chat and my locals Community it's like
that conversation is way better than
what goes on in the YouTube comment
section that's not a coincidence it's by
Design you know if you throw in a dollar
to be involved in something you will
care about it a little bit more I used
to joke with the entire local team I'd
be like you know what you know what
forget about the money for now why don't
we just literally make it a quarter why
don't we make our monthly uh
subscription 25 cents because I think if
people put 25 cents it'll it'll
basically cause them to behave about 90
percent better and I still believe that
there were a lot of logistical reasons
we couldn't do 25 with stripe cuts and a
whole bunch more but
there's a better thing happening there's
a better thing happening than the
Meltdown that we see everywhere uh and
actually right now why don't we bring in
Matt cores who is a can I call you a
financial Guru is that is that fair to
say Guru Guru I think just a guy who
maybe talks a little too much about
stocks I mean guys sometimes I get it
right sometimes I get it wrong guy who
talks too much about stocks well pretty
much everyone in the Sports World yeah
they sometimes just get it right and
sometimes get it wrong right I view it
as like the meteorologist of stocks like
if I get it wrong I just move on to the
next day there you go so so I want to
talk about the specifics of what's going
on with Rumble here how did you even get
involved in this whole thing you were
streaming on Rumble right before uh yes
right before the button was pressed or
the Bell was ringed so my involvement
with Rumble like it actually was because
of a very negative thing I was on a
competitor platform I was on YouTube and
not once not twice but three times my
channel was taken down because I was
harmful and dangerous
and that's crazy because I talk about
stocks yeah like I they're like a little
too much for us yeah and I most like
maybe I was caught up in an algorithm
but like I don't know like and that's
the point and I'm sure you with Steve
being on earlier like there is no
communication yeah no communication you
file you file your appeal and they're
like nope we reviewed your appeal and
we're not letting you back I'm like well
that's weird and then you read a little
bit more into it and you find out that
the same thing that initially banned you
is the thing that reviews your appeal
like the same automated system like yeah
it's crazy especially for
um a sub part of a company YouTube a
part of Google that it is a thing
because of the creators so to be treated
like that it's like ah whatever so I was
banned once terminated harmful and
dangerous Rumble reach out to me they DM
me and I didn't at that point in time a
little over a year ago I had never heard
about it and then it happened again and
then that time Chris personally reached
out to me he's like hey like I just want
to talk about what's going on and then
from there it was one of those like
light switch moments the light bulb went
on and I was like okay I get what's
going on yeah me talking about stocks
it's always risky where I was like why
would I not be on multiple platforms all
of a sudden all your eggs in one basket
and I see what you even personally do
you have to have most multiple
distribution Avenues so for me it was
kind of a no-brainer and at first I was
doing it and kind of like my YouTube
career nothing nothing nothing and I
have to say over the past month and a
half and maybe it's because it's in the
media more and now I'm sure with the
various announcements exclusive deals
with Russell Brand Steve will do it like
I think it's just going to get bigger
and bigger and bigger and for me the
biggest thing is like I get it if I do
something that's whatever illegal or
clearly against the TOs yeah okay there
should be punishment and you can talk
about it it's just more of like you
don't even know what you did you tell me
isn't it funny that that's the thing
that's driving us all crazy it's like
we'll all play by the rules if you guys
tell us the rules that's what I'm always
thinking with YouTube or when I when I
say something about gender or whatever
these it's like the rules are so
amorphous and and depend on who is
saying it and when they're saying it and
all this other stuff that that's the
part that makes it you can't build a
business like that and we're seeing it
time and time again across the entire I
guess we're really social media content
creation world is sometimes it says
random as just that reviewer that time
you're fine and whatever and the next
one doing the exact same thing they're
like nope that's for me I went from no
strikes to fully term and I was like
what about Shrek one two or three what's
going on here so it just from a business
sense I was like wow a company being
presented to me where they're like yeah
well let's just say what you want to say
and right now in the new digital age I
think people's voice and their opinions
are important so now that there's a
company who I feel very fortunate didn't
get stomped out by big Tech and it's
like infancy stages and made it to this
point which is a huge Rarity uh that
sense of protection and I feel like you
Steve and the other creators it's just
nice like you're like okay cool I don't
have to worry about that part of my
business when I need to worry about
other normal business I guess issues
right right it's it's a cost right there
when you have to worry oh if I say this
I'm taking out like you got to figure
out other ways to run your business so
putting aside why you're happy as a
Creator on Rumble and then they're not
going to mess with you you can say you
want in terms of what happened here
today and this company going public and
Free Speech being embedded into that can
you can you talk about that a little bit
Yeah so uh there's various ways to hit
the public market you have IPOs you have
direct listings and one that really
started to game Steam in 2020 was spec
deals it's a blank check company so
basically so this is what we did yeah
this is exactly what Rumble did through
Canter Fitzgerald so it was trading
under the ticker cfei and at that point
it's literally the best way I could
describe it is a pile of money it's just
sitting there and then they end up
getting a part of equity of a private
company so through that connection a
private companies trading on the public
market but that's kind of the first step
from there you get a big share holder
vote on if they want it to go through
and last week on Thursday that was the
vote for cfei shareholders of like do we
want to go through with the transition
to rumble they voted yes it was affirmed
everything on Friday so on Monday of
this week
um rum rum is the ticker symbol it hit
the public markets and now it's trading
as its own distinct company on listed on
the NASDAQ and to me so that's I guess
more and this was a rough year for specs
right like specs were really hot a year
ago two years ago but this is this I
think correct me for wrong is basically
like the cleanest back deal of the year
you are spot on I mean uhmath poly
apatia uh billionaire multiple times
over he recently actually a couple days
ago yesterday like had to pull out of
some of his fact deals like the ones who
were sponsoring it's been a rough time
so right now his buddy David sax from
the podcast is one of our investors and
locals so he's got to be happy with me
right now yeah definitely being able to
pull it off and so when it the all-in
podcast now happened like there's so
many cool threads that you could look at
this from and what I think is
interesting is okay so spax you're spot
on it's been a rough time it's a rough
time in the market we're not we're
officially as of yesterday's close in a
bear market and today on the last time I
checked it it is continuing so rough
overall Market where sometimes VC money
dries up people are a little
apprehensive which really you should be
doing the opposite but that's the story
for another time so rough overall Market
rough time for specs in the connotation
but then you see this one somehow not
just pull it off it wasn't like dragging
itself over the Finish Line it it ran
through it wasn't it point one percent
uh didn't go in on it from this back I
think yeah yeah and then they didn't
have the it was it was so absurdly good
this thing Usain Bolt through the Finish
Line it was like it was bragging it was
laughing it worked out super super well
and to me that just shows the power of
conceptually where this company is going
it's it's a very easy pitch it is a
platform that lets creators say what
they want to say with no fear of like oh
did I say that word is the outer like
you've experienced yourself if I say
that word I know the algorithm is going
to like really mess this one up so it
doesn't promote it to anyone like I mean
there's sometimes I before I do my show
in the morning when we're just you know
going through the rundown I'll be like
well I know what we're talking about
today so today is a no money Day on
YouTube it's an odd way to run a
business today there's gonna be no money
from that same thing that I always do
you have to get one of those like you do
it uh Happy mad octopus yeah it's a no
money day like you just put it on your
desk yeah yeah uh but to me it's cool
because there's some energy about like I
always think of it as like sometimes you
just stumble into the right direction
and sometimes you you stumble some of
someone and once in a while you take
that right step and you can tell it's
different and I'm sure you've had that
feeling many times with this is your own
business like there's probably times
where you're just like it's not working
why am I doing this one and then
something happens one day whether it's
the right DM the right Visa just
something abnormal and this this week
this time for rumble for me as a creator
for you and just like what this really
means for like the protection of any
form of Creator like whatever if you
want to post viral videos of a dog if
you want to talk about politics or
stocks or anything in between if you
just want to party like Steve and make
funny videos like the sense that you're
like protected and you're not always
worrying about like this looming thing
behind you like that weird tension you
just sleep a little bit easier it's the
thing that we all thought the internet
was going to be right is wasn't that the
promise of the internet 20 years ago
when everyone first got on YouTube we
didn't know what it was and you're
watching these cat videos and the woman
falling stomping the grapes and all of
those things and everyone thought it was
just like this open place and do your
thing and have fun and then it became
something very dark and twisted but yeah
that create creates a lot of opportunity
yeah and like for me it's interesting so
I'm 28 and I was speaking with my
parents about I'm like ah just things
are tense and it's not even just
political like in general there's like a
sense of unease and I was like was it
always like this I would argue it's
spurred by politics and like no it
wasn't like this this is a new Fresh
thing I was like all right that's
interesting and I'm of the mindset that
one of the best things you could do is
just talk like how can you possibly like
agree or disagree with the other side or
even your own side if we're not sharing
and pollinating ideas whether good or
bad the my argument is just the idea
should be out there I just want a
company and such as Rumble that is
willing to back that up and great as
long as we're all following the rules
that are very clear and on top of that
even if it goes sideways they talk to
you that's the biggest thing that I have
never had with any other form of social
media of like an actual human to human
interaction so really it comes down to
communication but on all levels across
the board and I love it now I'm going to
see if you're truly a professional
Creator because you can look at the
camera you can look right over there and
tell the good people where to find you
you can find me on all forms of social
media just Matt cords kohrs but
definitely check me out on Rumble Rumble
yeah definitely it's Matt cores like
there's no at or under thing like that
just
m-a-t-t-k-o-h-r-s and I'm happy to see
you there it's going to be a blast right
on thanks man I appreciate it awesome uh
guys I should mention by the way uh
because I know a lot of you are
wondering you do know that I was in Los
Angeles last night I don't think I slept
all day so I'm also operating on like 36
hours now of pure adrenaline but I was
in Crazy California in Psycho Los
Angeles last night I did Bill Maher's
podcast at his house it was the longest
podcast he's ever done he said it
afterwards that well he said a lot of
things I don't want to give away too
much before it airs but it was it was
great and much of what I've talked about
on the show for a couple years was we we
hacked at it we also didn't hack at it
we we made some built some bridges we
also butted some heads but it was it was
two decent people from slightly
different perspectives doing their thing
and that's what it's really all about
that so I relate that back to exactly
what's going on here at Rumble because
it's all about that plurality of voices
and finding a place where you can talk
about all the stuff and not worry about
getting banned okay I'm gonna just do uh
two or three more and and then we're
good to go I probably should take a nap
and eat something let's uh let's get
that on the agenda for today uh let's
see
um Ashley says was it weird to wake up
to no Mr burrito and Dr Clyde yes this
is the first day of my life since Justin
has been born that I'm not seeing him
and I'm going back in two days I'm on
Gutfeld tomorrow here in New York City I
do miss miss Mr burrito uh Clyde I've
traveled a little bit when Clyde's not
around but I do enjoy our our morning
walks thanks for asking and finally
Kevy says LA to New York City that's
like going from the fire into the frying
pan good luck today you've all worked
hard for this accomplishment well that
sounds like a nice way to end it I
appreciate that and really guys this is
this is just the beginning this is so
consistent this this public moment for
rumble and Free Speech being baked into
the ethos of the company I hope you got
a little insight from Chris and Assaf on
what we're trying to build and it's and
it's in a direct
it's in direct assault or in response of
all of the nonsense from Big Tech and
now we are going to assault them that is
the plan that is the plan that may not
sound like a pure business plan but it's
my plan I believe that David beat
Goliath and I believe that Dave can beat
Google and I believe that we can do it
together so why not right that's the
plan and on that note ladies and
gentlemen pretty cool I mean I'm doing
this from NASDAQ in Times Square my face
was in the middle of Times Square giant
billboard before I mean Nutty Nutty
absolutely nuts
thanks for watching Everybody uh we have
no live show tomorrow did we pre I don't
even know if we pre-taped anything no
live show tomorrow but uh I will be I'm
on Gutfeld tomorrow night and I'll be
back in studio on Monday and I
appreciate all the support and it's